the prime minister stopped short of
announcing a full
national lockdown but did warn the
option is still on the cards
if we fail to stem the rise in
infections he and his scientific
advisors think restrictions like the
ones announced today
are the best way to control the spread
of the virus
but is he right well the scientific
community
is divided on this issue on march the
23rd
the country went into full lockdown
quiet streets shuttered businesses
and empty classrooms since late spring
the government strategy has been to
impose
different restrictions for different
areas to deal with localized outbreaks
blackburn leicester bolton and newcastle
have all had different interventions
over the last few months
local lockdowns are published every week
in this
document and they've gone from a few
areas of concern
to more than a page of places
some interventions have worked in
curbing the spread and
some haven't which is why a more
standardized approach on restrictions
is being put into place take leicester
for example
cases rocketed to 140
per 100 000 people before restrictions
on household mixing
were put in place on the 29th of june by
the 17th of july
that rate was down to 16 per 100
000 and restrictions began to be relaxed
a week
later what we know from that leicester
lockdown is that testing
in the hot spot areas was ramped up and
testing with effective tracing and
isolating of symptomatic people
is what experts believe is critical to
the success
of any local lockdown but can that help
us
now the local
um handling of the pandemic if we did
have an effective test trace and isolate
system
and could work where there are just
local outbreaks
however we're in a situation that's gone
beyond local outbreaks
and we're in a situation where the test
trace and isolate system is currently
broken
we need a national series of
restrictions
it's a different story in bolton
restrictions were introduced there at
the end of july
when there were only 18 cases per 100
thousand but by the start of september a
sudden spike saw the area suffering
its highest seventh day rate of
infections
since late may and this meant
restrictions were increased
even further with a curfew on businesses
and no
indoor hospitality much like the
nationwide
measures announced today but there are
some scientists who believe
lockdowns are ineffective they think
vulnerable people
living in our communities should be
protected and then the virus should be
allowed
to run its natural course
one solution that is afforded by how
this virus behaves in the community
is really a simple one which is where we
allow herd immunity to accumulate
through natural infection among those
who are not vulnerable to death so if we
can
arrange for that to happen then
that is the simplest solution to the
problem
and that is not a pipe dream
that can be done by protecting
those who are vulnerable
it's a very difficult choice for a prime
minister trying to balance health needs
with the needs of the economy for now
he's listened to his advisers
who are urging restrictions but he has
not imposed a full
national lockdown if these measures work
he won't need to